within the first few days of Pokemon
goes July 2016 launch the app has
already been downloaded an estimated 7.5
million times in the United States alone
and by the time you're watching this
that number has skyrocketed Nintendo
stock soared as the game outperformed
all expectations people around the world
have gone crazy for the augmented
reality installment in the long-running
series which allows users to catch
pokemon battle the gems and collect
items in the world around them but
Pokemon go isn't all fun and games some
players have found injuries criminals
and even death on their adventures gotta
catch em all for Android users be wary
when downloading Pokemon go from any
source other than the Google Play Store
the Android operating system allows
users particularly those who have rooted
devices to download program files from
outside of the official app store and
install them on their phones for Pokemon
fans living in countries that can't
download the app officially yet these
files are the only way for them to get
early access to the game additionally
some of these files are targeted at
players who want to game the system
these cheat versions of the app
supposedly allow them to spoof their GPS
location in order to visit gyms and
catch pokemon without leaving their
couches the bad news enterprising
hackers have taken advantage of the
demand for these files releasing
versions of Pokemon Go packed with
viruses that take control of the user's
phone home invasion Pokemon Go
developers Niantic are also responsible
for another augmented reality game
ingress in that app users are encouraged
to visit claim and add local points of
interest for their team like a global
game of capture the flag these points of
interest were reused by an antic when
developing the map used by Pokemon go
unfortunately this has led to some
mishaps and confusion for players trying
to visit certain gems and polka stops in
Australia one local police station took
to social media to ask players to please
stop wandering into their station in
search of Pikachu Massachusetts resident
Boone Sheridan has it even worse he
bought an old Church in 2015 and
converted it into a home the church was
previously an ingress portal and is now
a gym in Pokemon go Sheridan reported
that he's lost count of the number of
players who have shown up at his
residence at all hours in the day and
Sheridan has made the best of the
situation venturing outside to meet some
of the visitors the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum in Washington
DC has taken a different stance on
dedicated Pokemon hunters while it
probably should go without saying the
museum recently issued a statement after
an influx of misguided visitors saying
quote we feel playing Pokemon go and a
memorial dedicated to the victims of
Nazism is inappropriate
we encourage visitors to use their
phones to share and engage with museum
content while here technology can be an
important learning tool but this game
falls outside of our educational and
memorial mission we are looking into how
the museum can be removed from it don't
be Tentacruel enterprising criminals in
O'Fallon Missouri have used the allure
of Pokemon go to draw unsuspecting
players into traps these criminals place
lore modules on pokus tops and remote
locations and waited for adventurers to
come running the modules increase the
chance of Pokemon appearing nearby which
in turn attracts more trainers to the
location to catch them after an unlucky
player showed up the thieves relieved
them of their belongings at gunpoint
you fools this wouldn't have happened if
you'd hand it over your Pokemon nicely
but now it's too late for that so I'm
going to take those Pokemon and destroy
you there were 11 such incidents in the
O'Fallon and st. Louis area over the
span of a few days
eventually the criminals were captured
following another stick-up and they were
charged with first degree armed robbery
and grand theft squirtle that's
definitely not a water type in rural
Wyoming 19 year old Pokemon go trainer
Shayla Wiggins set out to catch some
rare Pokemon near the big Wind River I
woke up this morning and I wanted to go
get a water pokemon so I just got up and
went for my little walk for a walk to
catch Pokemon when Wiggins realized she
was standing just a few steps away from
a corpse
she called the police no word on whether
or not Wiggins ever found that water
type Pokemon prepare for trouble Niantic
may have foreseen some of the issues
related to would-be Pokemon trainers
with their faces buried in their phones
especially after multiple tragic deaths
associated with ingress when you start
up a game a warning cautions trainers to
stay aware of their surroundings but
there are still been reports of players
who were just a little too focused on
catching that Flareon and ended up with
various injuries to show for it Lyn
Plunket a 23 year old waitress in
Asheville North Carolina tripped over a
cinder block while playing the game and
earned a colorful bruise on her right
shin one Reddit user claim that their
Pokemon go adventure ended up with a
trip to the local emergency room and
this is just a few days in how long
until the polka death toll spikes
blasting off at the speed of light while
we expected people to get fired from
their jobs for playing too much Pokemon
go
we weren't expecting someone to get
fired for not playing an Australian
expatriate had recently relocated to
Singapore in order to take a marketing
job for 99.04 ttle when he found out
that Pokemon Go wasn't available to play
in Singapore yet he took to social media
to vent his frustration publicly
naturally many native Singaporeans took
issue with his language insulting their
homeland and started arguing with him
online instead of apologizing for his
outburst he doubled down claiming that
he was there for work because the locals
quote can't even read and were only good
at quote and mouthing off it didn't take
long for the man's employer to find out
about his offensive online behavior 99
dot cos eyes and he found himself fired
from his position the very same day
which leaves him plenty of time to catch
them all job applications that is thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what crazy stories you've
heard about Pokemon go